question 10 goodness me question 10
remember when I showed you that
parametric's question yesterday and it's
just like poor you know paragraph of
texts you know this is kind of like whoa
there's like almost no numbers in this
question it's all algebra intrigue and
how do you even approach it so you
approach it by taking the first step
let's have like a panic show that the
roots are this is there to the six plus
Z cubed plus one equals zero are also
written Z to the nine minus one equals
zero okay so how are we trying to
understand this thing um you can see it
has to do with roots of unity when you
have a look at that bit on the end right
z to the nine minus one the solutions to
this other ninth roots of unity you see
that sets it what I'm solving for is
that to the ninth equals one okay so
ninth root of unity I want a marker now
when you look at this guy you think well
okay what can I do with him that connect
me to this right okay now it's not
immediately obvious right but that cube
code the ninth roots that equation that
I've got the polynomial that gives me
the nine through community is actually a
difference of cubes okay not super
obvious but if I write it out in such a
way because lines are power is multiple
of three I can write this as Z cubed
cute take away one cubed you care of
that so there's my difference of cubes
okay now the reason why I thought maybe
I should go towards that is because when
I have a look at this sky right this
isn't just remember I showed you a bit
of a fancy trick for factorizing is n to
the 9 minus one to remember that was n
to the N minus one we said this is n to
the N minus one is going to be Z take
away 1 times 2 remember what comes in
next it's the arm
it's the GP to the GP it went 1 plus Z
plus Z squared plus that up to but all
the way up to is n to the N minus 1 okay
now this is not a bad thought to have
like
to factorize in some way but you can see
it's not going to give us the answer
that we need because look how many terms
I have over here if I were to do this
guy I'd have um one plus Z plus Z
squared all the way up to Z to v8 okay
and also not only am I going to know all
well-said of the a but I'm I'm going to
have every one of the terms right every
power is it will appear
whereas here I'm missing a whole bunch
right so that's kind of no good and
that's why I leap towards okay what
other factorizations can I use
difference of cubes okay so let's write
the factorization for difference of
cubes here at the front
I've got Z cube minus 1 okay there's
that term there and then what do I have
over here on the right in silence okay
so it's usually like we just write just
on the side usually my difference of
cubes looks like this if I did say a
cube takeaway b cubed a usual
factorization is same officer X may be
always positive right you see that okay
now being that the thing that's being
cubed at the front is itself Z cubed
then the next thing that comes along is
n cubed squared said cube squared you
see that so that's why in fact I'm ever
going to write that as n cubed squared
so do you can see where my six comes
from okay my next bit is a peak which is
just 1 times they're cute and then my
last guy is one squared okay with that
so there is the piece that I was after
right so this whole thing is equal to
zero because I just factorized that I've
got Z cubed minus 1 and here is my Z to
the 6 happy times now what's the point
of that okay well when you factorize
something the whole point of factorizing
is if you have 0 on the right hand side
then the solutions to each of the
factors are solutions of the original
thing right so for example
when you have a quadratic and you
factorize okay the whole point is that
once you've got these factors right if
there's a solution for this that
solution will also solve this guy right
and you've got a solution for this it
will also be a solution of this guy so
therefore the solution to Zed to the 9
minus 1 are here and here okay so
everything that solves this will solve
your original and everything that solves
this will also solve your vision okay so
I can say therefore the roots of Zed to
the 9 minus 1 0 come from or a rise farm
these two factors right is n cubed minus
1 equals 0 and z to the 6 positive Q
plus 1 equals u that's all you need to
say you're finished ok I've established
that this and its solutions will be
solutions to this which is all they were
asking for show that the roots of this
guy I reserved this guy happy times ok
how will we the next part it's an easy
part visually surely those 9 roots on an
aegyo diagram identify which one of
them's which ones of them are the
solutions to it ok so let's just draw a
quick I go diagram okay
now because we're talking about roots of
unity and unity is a real number
what do I know about these 9 roots yes
that's right they're 2 pi online spaced
out around the circumference and also
because of the complex conjugate roots
theorem and one's a real number they're
all going to be paired up as conjugates
ok so I'm going to start with let's
let's draw our unit circle ok my first
solution of unity is always unity itself
slap that guy there okay
now as I draw the rest of them out okay
I need to fit there's my first solution
and how many solutions am I going to
have in time oh it feed the nitrous
immunity I will have 9 in total so I've
got another
Center on here okay so I know roughly
where they're going to fit to PI on nine
which is the next one up to PI online
where's that it's going to be roughly
I'm going to fit to four here ya go one
here and one here they're going to just
fit before PI on two because this will
be 2 pi or 9 this will be 4 PI on 9 what
is what's right on there in terms of
online it'll be before and 1/2 pi online
do you see that that's PI or 2 ok so
that's why I judge like I'm just trying
to give you practical tools for like
where roughly do I place these and then
I'm just going to keep going around so
here's my third one and there's my
fourth one okay or fifth depending where
you can 1 2 3 or 5 I've done all of the
ones for a positive principle argument
and clearly I can't go any further so
now I just do all the conjugate pairs
like so okay
roughly right now there are the 9th
roots ok I'm just going to quickly out
I'll draw the lines to each one if this
were an actual question like this was
disappearing in Museum you would need to
like what I would do is I would get my
calculator out and I would say okay what
is what is 2 pi or 9 and then it's going
to be a certain angle and it doesn't
have to be precise but has to be enough
that for instance I mean the classic
problem is we do these roughly ok and
then by the time you get to here your
your your estimates in so far off that
these two clearly do not look evenly
spaced along with the rest of them so I
actually don't think it's that bad an
idea to actually properly bring in a
protractor so you can like roughly at
least within like plus or minus a 5
degrees pop it in the right spot and
have your that would make a nonagon I
think it's got another one yeah that
would make your 9 sided regular polygon
look at least reasonable okay so I think
we're going to do that okay now I've got
all the UM nitrates of unity on there I
want to indicate which of them are
solutions to this one okay now in order
to think about that remember what I just
said all of the ninth roots
I the solutions of this all the
solutions of this okay
now this is just the cube roots of unity
I know them I know them really well
actually
which of these three other cube roots of
unity if I if I label them out what's
the first cube root one the first one is
just one so I'm going to call that Omega
one okay because I actually don't what
these solutions I work these solutions
some separating out these solutions
right where are my other two cube roots
of unity yeah they're going to be on
there give me these two guys right
that would be 2pi on three to get to
here and this should be minus two pi and
3 so I'm going to call this one Omega 2
and that makes this one Omega 3 not to
be confused with that fatty acid okay
now those are the roads I don't want
those in the cube root of unity
okay so I'm just going to say you know
these solutions or these roots are the
omegas okay so I separate them out and
these guys I'm going to call them as
Ed's the said ones in truth everyone's
I've actually after okay so I'm going to
say here the solutions are okay so I can
simply it with another color because
I've got them and we're just going to
name which one they are
there's z1 there - there's said three
and you'll notice because I've taken
immunity out of the out of the equation
the remaining roots are all complex
conjugates okay so just to help me later
on this is going to be very very useful
for you not only going that I'm going to
call this dead for I'm also going to
know that it is the kind of sorry that
four should be done it's the conjugative
Zed one yeah that's that's I'm pairing
these up down here I've got z5 which is
the conjugate of z2 and there's my last
one over here Zed six which is the
conjugate of Z three
okay and just as you expect because it's
a polynomial to the power of six you've
got six solutions I'm done okay